on est bien peu de chose et mon amie la
rose me l'a dit ce matin
alors je suis
baptisée ne rangeait je me suis épanoui
nous
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre neuvième
épisode du petit émir
la semaine dernière jean michel daniel
et chantal la couturière nous ont
présenté l'atelier costumes en compagnie
de leurs rêves et me more in thomas et
florian cette semaine nous retournons à
la ressource pour découvrir la troupe au
grand complet pour la toute première
fois
alors que jean michel et daniel sont
déjà sur place en compagnie de leurs
élèves l'arrivée de mary kay de sa
petite troupe déclenché une soudaine
bonne humeur
et l'ambiance se réchauffe encore plus
avec l'arrivée des jeunes de la montagne
joyeusement menée par maël
il faut dire que tous les comédiens se
découvrent pour la première fois et que
leur curiosité est très forte
ok mais c'est super les prix
pour une première répétition et la
ressource donc ce qu'on va faire pour
commencer chacun va se présenter dire
d'où il vient qu'est ce qu'il fait et
après on verra
c'est le moment pour chacun de se
présenter tout le monde a un peu le trac
et c'est bien normal pour une première
fois mais tous ceux se jette à l'eau
dans un esprit de joie et de partage
je travaille au collège
je suis
je suis ici à la ressource avec qui
isabelle mont éden bord comme un automne
jour je m'appelle match je suis à la
masse du sénat
et
donc pour apprendre le texte
au départ c'était un peu difficile
à la maison elle obtient aussi de l'aide
avec sa maman et on a vu aussi que vous
avez une relation particulière avec la d
league on s'est dit pourquoi pas mettre
deux personnes dans le même rôle
il avoue faire aller vite
maintenant que tout le monde se connaît
marica avec la troupe à visionner les
premières émissions en salle de
projection en route pour le deuxième
étage
tout le monde est désormais en place le
visionnage peut commencer pour certains
c'est la première fois qu'ils se
découvrent à l'écran surprise et émotion
sont au programme
après le visionnage c'est le moment pour
marika de nous dresser un petit bilan de
cette journée riche en émotions donc
ouais c'était super sympa d'être tous
ensemble aujourd'hui l'iem dans de la
montagne les percussionnistes qui joue
les villageois c'était vraiment sympa
aussi de que mathias walla de la masse
qui rencontrent les jeunes de la
ressource qui n'avait déjà pas encore vu
donc super c'était vraiment sympa et
voilà je pense que renée paule aussi qui
est déficient visuel et d'un lieu aussi
rencontrer tout le monde appréhendait le
groupe donc une belle rencontre et je
pense qu'on va bien travailler par la
suite et le fait se visionner de se voir
aussi sur un écran je pense que ça va
les aider les accompagner pour qu'ils
réalisent pas encore où est ce qu'on va
hélas de de voir ça sur une image et sur
des petits films ça donne du sens
vraiment à tout notre travail tout cas
de mise en scène et de création du
spectacle
et bien voilà vous connaissez maintenant
toute la troupe dans la prochaine
émission nous assisterons aux toutes
premières répétitions spectacle garanti
à très bientôt
nous